in working with the mother  the mother archetype it's very  important to remember that the feminine  is a force  of nature an energy  that can either give life  or take it away  children attempting to function in an  atmosphere that cannot sustain life  suffer bodily and psychically  they fear life itself  the compensating dream will be  of a loving mother  now other children blessed with parents  who  are able to give them the honey of life  may have strong positive feminine images  compensating for the loss in the culture  the one is an individual loss the other  a cultural  loss the full moon  is one of those radiant images that can  bring the dreamer into himself  then take him off the ground into a  universal world of stars and spheres  and he can become lost in the harmony of  that space  it is very important with such dreams  that you recognize the compensation  essential to stay on the ground  and not be lost in the harmony  of the spheres